[Música]
qué pasaría
si tú tú tú dejas de comer 24 horas
probablemente te dolería el estómago te
pondría de mal humor pero si después de
las 24 horas comes ya te quedaste feliz
si dejas de tomar agua 8 horas te va a
dar se te vas a sentir tal vez te duela
un poquito la cabeza porque te
deshidratas pero tomas agua o algún
líquido y de nuevo estás perfecto o
perfecto
pero qué pasa si dejas de respirar tres
minutos
tres minutos
bueno te cuento una cosa vas a estar
muerto muerta porque a menos que seas
buzo o los pescadores de perlas que
están entrenados en aguantar la
respiración
creo que no duramos más de un minuto
porque nos falta oxígeno y empiezan a
ver convulsiones y nos morimos entonces
se dan cuenta que tan importante es la
respiración para la vida
podemos dejar de comer dejar de tomar
agua pero dejar de respirar no se puede
y sabes que respiramos cuando estamos en
la calle que pasa en auto para todos
lados que hay a lo mejor alguna fábrica
por ahí
o qué pasa que está respirando en este
minuto aquí en que estamos como 100
personas en un lugar cerrado
que está respirando
sabe
yo creo que oscarito sabe por aquí está
pero bueno cuando en alguna oportunidad
que ustedes se hayan encontrado en una
habitación cerrada que el sol está
afuera y que por un pedacito de la
cortina abierta entra un rayo de sol
que se ve
puntitos verdad a los niños cuando les
pregunto en los primeros dicen puntitos
bueno son partículas esas partículas son
de gases o también pueden ser pole en
polvo etcétera pero lo que respiramos de
oxígeno es dióxido de carbono son todas
esas partículas que aquí no las estamos
viendo pero si están en la calle tampoco
las vemos pero si están incluso hay en
las grandes ciudades y también acá
dentro de lo que estamos respirando son
metales y eso nos hace muchísimo daño
para tener enfermedades o para que las
enfermedades que tengamos se agraven
bueno el tema es
saben ustedes quien nos limpia el aire
las plantas los árboles
entonces un árbol es muy importante no
sólo porque es hermoso no sólo porque
cobija a las aves sino porque nos da
oxígeno
y ahora les voy a pedir que nos
imaginemos que todo esta ventana es de
vidrio de vidrio todo es de vidrio y lo
que vemos en la calle y yo les estoy
conversando a ustedes diferentes cosas
pero de repente sentimos mucho ruido de
lluvia y no ha llovido ha que hace
tiempo y queremos la lluvia y todos
miramos a la ventana pero en lugar de
agua están cayendo dólares y euros
sí y libras y yenes y eso que harían
ustedes
yo le pido permiso y me voy y me saco la
chaqueta y empiezo a recogerlo o no
bueno pero les cuento que lo que hacemos
es tan tonto lo que hacemos acá en la
lluvia que es más valiosa que el oro que
el yen que el todo estamos en un
desierto donde no hay nada y tenemos una
caja de de euros no nos quita la sed
el agua es en la sangre de la vida y en
este minuto estamos en crisis de agua
probablemente algunos de ustedes les
falta el agua la tienen algunas horas
miren el chile hay una crisis del agua
tanto que el presidente habló de que va
a hacer cosas
porque la crisis del agua la crisis
hídrica se da por una gran sequía que
hay allá de años y no solamente eso sino
que se agrava porque el agua es privada
allá
entonces en todo el mundo el tema del
agua es terrible y resulta que cuando
llueve dejamos que corramos las calles
que rompan las calles después alegamos
que hay baches
y sin embargo cuando hay sequía no la
cuidamos de aquí
dice que somos inteligentes bueno hay un
señor un señor chino un arquitecto
urbanista que se llama el señor yoo el
nombre no me acuerdo
el señor yo él estuvo en méxico hace
poquito la unam y dio una plática
sumamente interesante porque él habla de
esto él como científico como estudioso
habla de inundaciones graves las sequías
graves
de repente llueve mucho y nosotros como
somos tan inteligentes hemos construido
casas a la bajada de los cerros entonces
el agua cae arrastra lodo perjudica las
casas y después decimos qué tragedia o
sea provocada por los humanos bueno
entonces a raíz de eso él hace proyectos
que ya tiene china en eeuu en alemania y
llama ciudades se esponja
una serie de tecnologías para que la
ciudad reciba el agua de la lluvia y la
y se pueda cuando se necesita
entonces volvemos al árbol el árbol está
en el suelo en la tierra tiene raíces
cuando llueve el agua se va por sus
raíces y se va a los mantos freáticos
entonces está actuando como una esponja
que se vaya el agua a los mantos
freáticos si tenemos muchos árboles que
es lo que va a pasar que va a haber más
captación de agua
entonces el árbol no sólo nos da oxígeno
también nos permite tener recuperación
de agua además él transpira tose también
nos está haciendo que el ambiente sea
mejor para la respiración
bueno
en el año 2001 un grupo de amigos
decidimos hacer una organización
ambientalista porque
mucho nos preocupaba mucho el tema
de la basura del agua del aire muchas
cosas ambientales de la comida entonces
decidimos que nos hablaran mucha gente
nos pusimos en contacto con profesores
de la universidad con gente que
trabajaba en coma para la cosa del agua
etcétera y llegamos a la conclusión que
necesitábamos educación educación
ambiental o más bien educación para la
vida
entonces en ese tiempo nosotros íbamos a
pasear a un área que se llamaría
campestre se llamaba que está en el
parque siglo 21 entonces nos dimos
cuenta que allí había una gran
biodiversidad flora y fauna más de 200
especies de plantas más de 100 especies
de aves ardillas víboras arañas hormigas
camaleones conejos liebres zorros
coyotes un tesoro a 10 minutos de aquí
que estamos el centro de la ciudad
entonces dijimos esto es un tesoro hay
que cuidarlo es una fábrica de agua
fábrica de oxígeno y nos comprometimos
con los animales de ahí a cuidarle su
hábitat que finalmente en provecho de
nosotros los humanos
bueno en ese tiempo yo fui a chile fui a
ver a mis padres a mis hermanos a mi
amigo etcétera y le conté a mi papá que
estábamos haciendo un bosque urbano en
esta organización ambientalista
me dijo haciendo que
un bosque urbano papá en la ciudad
porque está ahí en la ciudad en todo
esto hay plantar y etcétera visita está
loca y sus amigos también un bosque un
bosque está hecho dios lo hizo como lo
hacen usted eso es soberbia
pues sí yo me quedé pensando suena
soberbio pero es que como seres humanos
hemos destruido tanto pero demasiado a
los niños que vienen que están
chiquititos les estamos dejando una
mugre estamos dejando un mundo terrible
entonces
no es soberbia
es un deber es un deber y un querer
hacerlo
y a eso por eso vine por eso acepté esta
invitación cosa que me hicieron para
convencerlos a ustedes de que nos ayuden
a hacer este bosque urbano
es muy difícil es muy complicado porque
tenemos muchas cosas en contra de la
gente que estamos en esto tienen marido
trabajo hijos
por último ganas de hacer otras cosas
y para hacer esto hay que tener
constancia valentía conciencia y sobre
todo sobre todo amor
porque eso como que suaviza todo si
alguien nos regaña a alguien de gobierno
nos dice ustedes que tienen que hacer
x pues
lo miramos con la dulzura de decirle
pues lo hacemos por sus hijos y seguirá
adelante a pesar de los incendios a
pesar de que roban llaves de que rompen
etcétera seguimos pero seguimos porque
tenemos un convencimiento de que no
podemos dejar de hacer algo
estamos en emergencia climática
españa y otros países ya declararon la
emergencia climática
nos quedan muy poquitos años para poder
revertir esto y tenemos que hacerlo
bueno es muy difícil pero les voy a
contar que hemos tenido logros grandes
uno es que el año 2015 después de hacer
mucha subida bajada a recoger firmas ir
y venir
y logramos que el gobierno del estado
declarara área natural protegida
al bosque urbano y al jardín botánico
que está ahí mismo que queda donde atrás
del museo tamux
eso se logró gracias a los ángeles que
tenemos
la organización tiene ángeles que son
maestros de la universidad autónoma de
tamaulipas maestro de la universidad de
la salle que de diferente manera nos han
dado argumentos científicos para poder
ir con los políticos y con el gobierno y
decirle esto no se lo pedimos que se
haría natural protegida porque nos da la
gana sino porque necesitamos tener todo
esto y ya está lo que hay que hacer es
conservar reforestar y cuidar hacerlos
jardines para polinizadores un bosque no
es solamente un conjunto de árboles
además tiene que ser de árboles de la
región si ponemos acá 45 grados de calor
un bosque de pinos
hay que poner aire acondicionado
entonces tenemos que aprender a admirar
lo que existe acá
aquí el chaparral espinoso bajo los
maravillosos ébanos las aguas la sana
cagüitas las el cenizo bueno en lo que
les pido es que se sumen se sumen a
estas actividades
si están aquí en vitoria todos los
sábados los esperamos ahí si son de
otras ciudades en su ciudad rescate en
algún lugar donde haya algún tipo de
biodiversidad nativa y defiendan los
necesitamos por las generaciones que
vienen
hagamos escuchemos a greta thunberg esa
niñita de 17 años que es sueca
que dice les dice a los políticos a los
gobernantes al papá a todos los que
manda en este mundo les dice escuchen a
los científicos los científicos ya
hicieron el diagnóstico de todo lo que
está mal y están dando las soluciones
y los políticos no las toman
pero nosotros como sociedad civil no nos
podemos quedar con las manos cruzadas
tenemos que hacer cosas
organícense participen sus meses
lo único que no se puede hacer es
cruzarse de brazos
los invito de verdad a que entreguen
solidaridad alegría porque es una tarea
linda ahí se conoce gente que es muy
simpática que piensan lo mismo que tiene
valores que compartimos muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]